[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
97 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how, are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am very well.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty happy.
Back from Chicago.
You're back from your favorite
conference of all time.
MARK MANDEL: Strange Loop.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
And we're in the same
place at the same time!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I don't see new
Strange Loop t-shirt.
MARK MANDEL: I was
wearing it yesterday.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, OK, that's why.
MARK MANDEL: That's why.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good.
Good, not to be using the
same t-shirt over many days.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Anyway, so today, we're
going to have something
really special,
because two managers
from the Firebase team
are here to talk about something
that was announced yesterday.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We're pretty quick.
Cloud Firestore.
Dun, dun dun!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which
is an amazing thing.
If you love Firebase's
Realtime Database,
it is basically something
similar, but even more
powerful.
So if you have
huge scaling needs,
or you need to do a
really cool filtering,
stuff like that, Cloud
Firestore is for you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and if you
want that Realtime Database
goodness as well,
it's pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is
really, really cool.
And we're going to have both
Dan McGrath and Alex Dufetel.
They're going to
tell us all about it.
And after that, we'll
have our question
of the week, which is not
about Cloud Firestore,
but about Cloud Datastore.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we're going
to have a quick chat about,
I've got stuff in the
Datastore, but I'd really
like to be able to
export it, maybe
so I can use it locally
or in other things.
How do I do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah--
backups, stuff like that.
Maybe you want to export
it into, I don't know,
BigQuery or whatever,
many ways of doing it.
And we have something new that
we're going to discuss on that.
But before all of this, we have
our cool things of the week.
And the first one
is something that I
think is-- it was really cool
that we announced it, like, oh,
by the way, we are
announcing per second billing
on Google Cloud Platform.
That was like OK,
we've done that, good.
I find it's a very
nice blog post.
Go read it and let us
know what you think.
I think it's a
very well-written--
MARK MANDEL: Yes, I agree.
No, I like it.
I like it a lot.
Actually, it's kind of
cool that-- the one thing
I like about it is it does
talk about the difference
between per-minute and
per-second billing.
Going from per
hour to per minute,
the amount of money that you're
going to save is quite large.
Whereas going per minute
to per second-- meh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
With one, you can buy coffee.
With the other one, you
can buy a coffee machine.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
I love that.
I love it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
yeah, it was really cool.
Previously, the only thing
that were billed per second
were actually persistent disks.
And I think there's also
the use discounts on GPUs,
but now it is basically
all of the things.
So you have Compute Engine,
Container Engine, Cloud
Dataproc, App Engine Flexible.
And the cool thing is that
this was announced as something
that was like, it is going to
be implemented, but not really.
It was September 26--
was like, oh, by the way,
this is effective now.
So you're already saving money.
You don't need to do anything.
It's just there.
MARK MANDEL: Just there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which is cool.
Let's go to the second two cool
things of the week actually.
Two new languages are general
availability on App Engine.
So yeah, so we have PHP 7.1.
And I'm not a PHP
expert by any way.
But one of the
things that is cool
is that it has now support for
Stackdriver logging and error
reporting.
Which is really
important, because if you
have an application running
on production, being
able to see what is going
on, and when it fails,
understand how it failed--
it is really important, and
Stackdriver helps with that.
And then we also have Java 8.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
Java 8, very simple.
And obviously, something people
wanted for a very long time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, but now that
means if you want to use Java
8, basically just add Java 8
line to your appengine-web.xml
file, redeploy your application,
and you're pretty much good
to go.
And it was pretty cool,
during the beta release,
they continued to enhance the
performance of the runtime
such that so many customers
were able to see benefits
going all the way
through on that platform.
But now, you can use Java 8.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and something
that is mentioned quite quick,
but I think it's really, really
important is the fact
that with Java 7,
there was a lot of limitations,
among other things,
on security on the ClassLoader.
And that limited the number of
classes that you could load.
So there was that
wide list of classes,
or Java classes
that were supported.
That has been removed.
And the same thing for the
usual thread execution, which
I wonder how unusual that was.
MARK MANDEL: I wonder
what that means.
There's a story there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
yeah, those two things
have been completely removed.
So App Engine with Java 8
is basically just Java 8
on App Engine, and
nothing special.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
you can use Jetty 9,
fully outbound gRPC connections.
You can do all
sorts of cool stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, very, very cool.
Very excited about that, really.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So, of course, one of my
favorite topics, Kubernetes.
Kubernetes 1.8 has
now been released.
This time it's more-- it looks
like spotlight on security,
workload support, some
new features in RBAC.
I'm pretty excited.
CronJobs finally have come
out of alpha and now beta.
That makes me super happy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is good
that it makes you happy,
but it feels like something
so obvious and simple.
But if you need it--
MARK MANDEL: It's useful.
It's a thing that you need to do
across a cluster machine once,
right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: It's now in beta.
That's great.
So there's a lot of work there
being done for actual data
storage, things like that.
If you want to do key value
stores, or some kind of storage
engine, stuff like that,
that's the stuff that's
really been solidified.
So yeah, another great release
from the Kubernetes team.
Rolling that out,
just really kind of--
doesn't have to be
big and splashy.
Just another good thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And congratulations
to the Kubernetes community.
Because the pace at
which they release
new features is amazing.
So congratulations to them.
MARK MANDEL: Now, one thing
that is cool if you run on GKE,
and you run on us, there
is some new stuff on us.
The one thing I will mention--
we'll link to the blog post.
There's a bunch of stuff.
But now, if you go
into the Cloud Console,
we have a bunch
more of doohickeys
that you can basically look at.
So there's a lot
more information
that you can see about what's
running inside containers,
and you can basically start
doing development tasks
inside the UI.
There's improved integration
with Stackdriver and Cloud
Shell.
You can have a look
in the blog post,
but there's some pretty
sweet stuff in there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And for the last cool thing
of the week that we're
going to mention
really quick, it
is the fact that we're
announcing Cloud IoT Core
public beta.
And we will have an
episode on Cloud IoT,
so we'll not get too
much into detail.
But basically, if you are
managing a fleet of devices,
IoT devices, and you need
to manage them, manage
the certificates, make sure
that the connection is safe,
and all of these
things, and that you're
able to connect with all of them
and gather metrics from them,
IoT Core is exactly
for this use case.
And check it out.
It is now public beta,
so it's definitely
the moment to go play with it
and let us know what you think.
MARK MANDEL: IoT all the things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: IoT
all the cores, things.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So why don't we go have
a chat with Dan and Alex
and talk all about
Cloud Firestore?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
So I am very excited to
welcome two product managers
from Firebase, both of them
working in the Cloud Firestore
team, Dan McGrath
and Alex Dufetel.
How are you both doing?
DAN MCGRATH: Excellent,
good morning.
ALEX DUFETEL: Hey.
Doing well, good morning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're going
to be talking about the latest
product that was launched
yesterday for Firebase,
which is Cloud Firestore.
But before we get into
all of the cool details
about this new
product, why don't you
tell us a little bit
about yourselves,
what you do on Google?
Let's start with you, Dan.
DAN MCGRATH: I'm a product
manager on the Cloud Firestore
team, also working
on Cloud Datastore.
And before that, I
was on Google Drive.
ALEX DUFETEL: So I'm a PM on the
Cloud Firestore team as well.
I also work on the
Firebase Realtime Database.
And prior to joining
Firebase, I actually
ran and sold a company
that was powered
by Firebase products,
which I'll probably
touch a little bit on later.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So we're here to
talk about Firestore.
Clearly, Firebase didn't
have enough cool things,
so we're just going to add
one more extra cool thing.
Who wants to tell us
an overview level--
what is Cloud Firestore?
ALEX DUFETEL: So Cloud Firestore
is a fully managed NoSQL
database.
It comes as the second
database offering
in the Firebase portfolio.
So users will now
have two databases
that they can choose from, the
Realtime Database and Cloud
Firestore.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So you mentioned
it's a non-relational
database, which
makes me think about Bigtable.
But I'm also assuming that
it has all the goodness
from the Realtime
Database, so it's still
that real-time nature of it.
ALEX DUFETEL: Right.
So stepping back a little
bit, Cloud Firestore
addresses many of the
limitations of the Realtime
Database.
The Realtime Database has
long been the flagship product
of Firebase.
It was among its first
offering of products,
and it solved many, many hard
problems that developers have.
One, it makes it very easy to
imagine and scale your backend.
And it allows developers to
power real-time features,
which are, without proper
tooling, very difficult
to build.
And it also allows for--
to build offline ready apps.
The problems with the Realtime
Database is that as we scale--
the Realtime Database is
a very successful product
with hundreds of thousands
developers using it.
But as the database
scaled, and as we've
started having more usage,
usage patterns evolved.
And what we saw is people
are using the database
across all their app needs,
not just the real-time bits.
And as they were
doing so, they really
hit two different
types of limits.
The first is around data
structuring and querying,
and the other is
around scalability.
What happens with
the Realtime Database
is that if you want to build
very sophisticated apps
and access your data in
very sophisticated ways,
you sometimes have to structure
it in convoluted ways.
And the other thing is
it scales very well,
but beyond a certain limit, you
need to start creating shards.
And those are the core problems
that Cloud Firestore solves.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So could you tell me more about
where those limits are more
or less, so our audience can
have any idea of whether they
should be using the Realtime
Database or Cloud Firestore?
ALEX DUFETEL: The scalability
limit of the Realtime Database
is most often expressed as
the number of concurrent users
that you can have.
And those are
approximately 100,000.
We put this as a hard limit.
You may actually hit some
scalability issues before that.
But most of the time, this
is what you can reach.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 100,000
concurrent users.
ALEX DUFETEL: That is a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is a lot of data.
Yeah, that is.
That's a big party.
Let's look a little bit
more about what people
were doing with the
Realtime Database
and how that motivated
this Cloud Firestore story.
You mentioned that the
way you were modeling data
before was sometimes awkward.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that
and how Cloud
Realtime is different?
ALEX DUFETEL: Right.
So first, I'd like to start
with some of the things that
are similar--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
ALEX DUFETEL: --with
the Realtime Database.
So first, like the
Realtime Database,
Cloud Firestore features
rich client SDKs
that allow you to build directly
from web, iOS and Android.
And that's really a
big deal, because it
allows you to access your data
directly from your clients.
And it basically
allows you to not
have to build a proxy
layer to do all the access
control, the data validation,
and the delivery of data
to your app.
So it saves you a lot of time.
This is made possible in the
backend by a set of security
rules that developers
can define that basically
allow you to define who and
how your data can be accessed.
So along the way, this model
of client SDKs with rules
also makes it much easier
to build more secure apps.
The second thing that is similar
with the Realtime Database
is that Cloud Firestore
allows you to fetch
your data in real-time.
Time.
Now this is actually
a very, very big deal.
On the surface, you
may think that is great
because it allows you to
build real-time functionality.
Typically, you want to build
a collaborative whiteboard,
or you want to build
a messaging app,
and having a real-time database
for that is really cool.
While that's true,
the advantages
of having a real-time database
extend way beyond that.
In particular, one of the
things it allows you to do
is to just build much
more reactive apps.
The other thing is
nowadays, very often,
you need to sync your data
across potentially multiple
devices.
And you get that out of the
box with the Realtime Database.
MARK MANDEL: Does this also
work, say, offline and online?
I know Realtime Database had
that as an option as well.
ALEX DUFETEL:
Right, so actually,
that is one of the
features that I
think our group of developers
testing the Cloud Firestore so
far has been most
excited about it.
Because it's something
that's very complicated
to build as a
developer, because you
need to build all
the sync logic,
the conflict resolution logic.
And Firestore does this
completely behind the scenes.
It does this for
Android, for iOS,
and now, it does this for
web as well, which is unique
and wasn't available for
the Realtime Database.
For those listening,
one of the things
that is really
powerful with this
is there's really two
things to offline.
One is kind of the
vanilla use case, which
is, I want to use my app
offline purely-- say I'm going
on the plane, I have no Wi-Fi.
I want to use my app
for a couple of hours,
and then when I reconnect,
all my data gets synced back.
But there's another
aspect which is just as
important, is what we
call latency compensation.
And what that is
is basically, we
switch between
offline and online
behind the scenes for you
so that we can compensate
for network flakiness.
So say you're in the
airport, you have poor Wi-Fi.
What typically happens
in the normal app
is your app slows down as
your requests slow down.
With Cloud Firestore,
what happens
is that we automatically
serve you what's in the cache,
or we cache your rights to wait
for your network to be back
to sync those changes.
So as a user, your app
continues working beautifully.
MARK MANDEL: And
that's a new feature?
ALEX DUFETEL: No,
latency compensation
was available for the
Realtime Database.
But now it's available
for web as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So now it's available for web
as well with Cloud Firestore?
ALEX DUFETEL: With
Cloud Firestore.
So just back to the
data model question.
So Cloud Firestore features
a familiar collection
and document model.
And this model is
architected-- it
has a little bit of a twist over
typical collection documents,
because it allows you
to very easily structure
your data hierarchically.
And the reason why
this is important
is that it allows you to
tie related data together.
And, as we've seen, this
is the most intuitive way
to store your data.
And what we've learned
with the Realtime Database
is that it is
extremely important
that the intuitive
design patterns are also
the right ones.
This has two effects.
One, so it considerably
accelerates the learning curve
when you're starting
to use the product.
But even more importantly,
it prevents you
from having to re-architect
your data as your app grows.
So it's something that
we're very excited about.
The second thing that
we're very excited about
is that this data model comes
with very expressive queries,
which is really new compared
to the Realtime Database, which
had a very, very basic
querying language.
And last but not
least, these queries
are extremely performant.
So we've actually architected
the database and our queries
in a way that all queries
scale with the results set,
not the data set.
So what that means that is that
if you're querying, fetching
one result out of 100,
or out of 100 million,
you'll get the same performance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: That's really nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So could
you talk a little bit
about the query capabilities
of both the Realtime
Database and Cloud Firestore?
What kind of things can you do?
ALEX DUFETEL: So typically,
with the Realtime Database,
you were limited to a
filter on a single property.
With Cloud Firestore, you can
filter on multiple properties,
you can mix equalities
and inequality filters.
You can do offsets, you
can do cursor positions.
You can do quite a
bit of fancy things.
MARK MANDEL: Can
you do aggregations?
Like if you want
to use this report?
Or is it not really
that kind of tool?
ALEX DUFETEL: No, you
cannot do aggregations.
DAN MCGRATH: No.
You can do small aggregations
on the client side,
taking into account
the scalability factor
of returning result set rather
than dataset sides latency.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you mentioned that
when you're doing filters,
you're doing filters on
properties, among other things.
Those properties-- is there
a schema for people that
don't know that much about--
there's NoSQL, so I'd say no.
But is there, somewhere, a
list of all the properties?
DAN MCGRATH: So
like you mentioned,
it's really a
schema-less database.
So that means every
document can have
its own independent schema.
You can get a list of fields
back from each document
and query out against them,
but it makes it really easy
to continually evolve your app
as you add new fields to it.
You don't need to go back
and alter tables and wait
for things to rebuild.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So this sounds super cool.
I'm going to ask the
question as well.
Apart from the
client side, is there
ways of interacting with
that on the backend?
Is there a server
integration part?
DAN MCGRATH: Yeah, absolutely.
We actually have a set of
server SDKs you can use,
whether it's compute VMs,
or a Kubernetes cluster,
or even [INAUDIBLE]
you're running locally
on your machine.
So we've got Java,
Python, Node.js, and Go--
several client
libraries available.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So what are those servr--
or backend is the
case, useful for?
What kind of use case have you
seen people using them for?
DAN MCGRATH: Many
different ones.
Two quick examples
are integrating
with existing systems.
So you're writing
a new mobile app,
and you want data updates
to be reflected out
into your mobile app or website.
You can do that via
those server SDKs.
The other big one is offline
big-batch processing.
You want to update something
or add new data into it.
That's very easy to do.
Just spin up a compute
VM, and off you go.
MARK MANDEL: And
since server-less
is the new hotness, is there
some sort of Cloud Function
type thing going on?
ALEX DUFETEL: Sure.
So Cloud Firestore allows you to
integrate with Cloud Functions,
allowing you to trigger
code on writes and deletes.
MARK MANDEL: And edits?
ALEX DUFETEL: And edits.
[LAUGHING]
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Cool.
So what does the development
experience look like?
Is this integrated in the
usual Firebase tooling?
Like If I want to play with
this thing, what am I writing?
ALEX DUFETEL: So first, if you
want to play with this, head
to Firebase, create a project.
And then download--
so you can either
use it from the client
SDKs, iOS, Android, or web,
or the server SDKs we
were talking about.
Just download the
SDKs, load your config,
and you're ready to go.
MARK MANDEL: That's it?
DAN MCGRATH: That's it.
ALEX DUFETEL: Pretty much, yeah.
Very easy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
one of the things
that I love about
Firebase Realtime
Database is that
dashboard where you can
see the data on real-time time.
And if your program
changes something,
it just changes
colors and stuff.
It's amazing.
And it's, for demos,
the best thing ever.
Does Cloud Firestore also
support these kind of things?
ALEX DUFETEL: Yes, it does.
It is something that we're
also very excited about.
I think when I first discovered
Firebase many years ago,
it was actually my
co-founder had discovered it
over the weekend.
And he showed me his laptop
with that dashboard and things
changing in real-time.
He had created a whiteboard--
so we were in collaboration,
he had created a whiteboard.
He showed me how you
could move a square
around the white
board, and those
coordinates would update in
real-time and through the data
viewer.
And we were hooked.
And it was funny.
It was really funny.
And this was really core to
the experience of the Firebase
database, and so it
really mattered to us
that we'd be able to provide a
similar experience with Cloud
Firestore.
So we did our best to
do something as cool.
And we look forward to having
feedback on what we did.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So all of this
sounds really great,
and you talked about
some comparisons
between the Realtime Database
and the new Cloud Firestore.
Does this mean if
I'm sitting down,
I've got a greenfield project,
I'm going to build a thing.
Should I use Realtime Database?
Should I use Cloud Firestore?
Which one should I use?
ALEX DUFETEL: So we're
recommending for new apps
to use Cloud Firestore
for developers
who are comfortable
using a beta product.
That's the short answer.
The long answer is you can
use both products together.
For most use cases,
Cloud Firestore
will be the best solution.
For certain edge cases,
the Realtime Database
might make more sense to
use from a cost-efficiency
perspective.
And the reason
for this is that--
so first of all, the
costs of operating
Cloud Firestore and
the Realtime Database
are not the same, because
one is a replicated database,
and the other is not.
And so typically, with
the Realtime Database,
something that is
very, very efficient
and cost-efficient is to update
small bits of data very fast.
So say you're building a
collaborative whiteboard,
and you want to move
a cursor around,
and you sync that
position, and you
want to sync that
several times a second.
This is something that the
Realtime Database is well
built for, because you're only
charged for outgoing bandwidth.
So even if you're doing
many, many document writes,
it's still OK.
This model with Cloud Firestore
doesn't make as much sense,
because, first of all,
we're replicating your data
for additional reliability.
And that type of data
doesn't make sense
to be replicated
in that use case.
And Cloud Firestore
charges per operation,
so you're charged for every
write, and delete, and edit.
Which is actually more
intuitive for most use cases,
but for this use case, for
example, it's less performant.
So in this type of
scenario, what we're telling
users is it's perfectly fine
to use both databases together.
The other thing
is both databases
will live alongside in
the Firebase console.
And if you're using the
Realtime Database today,
it is totally fine
to continue using it.
We'll be supporting
and developing
both products going forward.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So when you say that you can use
both of them at the same time,
that doesn't mean that the
data is replicating to both.
It's that you have two
different databases,
and you should
choose either one.
ALEX DUFETEL: That's it.
You can also use Cloud Functions
to replicate data from one
place to another very easily.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you
mentioned real quick something
that is actually really
important for our audience,
which is data replication.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about it?
DAN MCGRATH: Yeah,
I'll take that one.
Alex mentioned it's a
replicated database,
so I'll tell you a
little bit about how
it works under the covers.
It's what we call a multi-region
replicated database.
And that means whenever
you write data,
we're committing it not just
to one or two data centers.
We're committing
it to multiple data
centers across distinct
geographical regions.
So when you commit data, it
actually is durable, even
in the face of disasters.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Does that
mean that those replicas also
cam take the reads?
So if your audiences,
or your user base
is distributed geographically,
they will get the fastest?
DAN MCGRATH: Yeah, I think
probably the most important
thing to note first off is Cloud
Firestore goes across Google's
internal network.
So that means we're going
to in-bound your request
from the closest
point of presence,
regardless of what
country you're in,
and use our fiberoptics to get
you to the right data center
to serve data.
Each data center
that we replicate
to can serve data out of it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
What about rights?
Basically, my question
is, is it master, active--
all of them are active and
can take the reads and writes?
Or do you always need to go
to one, and the other one,
it just reads replicas?
DAN MCGRATH: Yeah, so we are in
an active-active configuration.
Our system will
automatically route
to where we think
the quickest is going
to be to start with, though.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Do you get to configure
how many replicas you get?
Or is that a fixed
number that is
the safest bet, and that's it?
DAN MCGRATH: So this is a fully
managed solution by Google.
That means Google engineering
takes care of everything
for you-- node count, RAM
allocation, cluster management.
It's all handled
by us, so you just
need to think about
how you use the SDK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Mark
was mentioning before,
if I'm to build
something from scratch,
which one should I be using?
I'm already using
Realtime Database, right?
Firebase Realtime Database.
Under what conditions
would you say
that Cloud Firestore
is something
that I should
consider moving to?
ALEX DUFETEL: So there's
a couple of, I guess,
scenarios where it makes sense.
One is, if you want to
implement new functionality that
will require some
complex querying,
then definitely give
Cloud Firestore a try.
Also, if you're really
interested in getting
the benefits of the
multi-regional data sync,
then definitely use
Cloud Firestore.
And again, you can
use both together.
So what we've been
seeing with our testers
so far, especially those who
are using the Realtime Database,
is that you can typically
just implement a new feature,
have some of that data
live in Cloud Firestore
and use Cloud
Firestore for that.
MARK MANDEL: And it also
sounds like there's some web
capabilities that you
wouldn't necessarily
be able to get inside
Realtime Database,
so that my be a
driving factor, too.
ALEX DUFETEL: Yeah, exactly.
So if you want to power
an offline-ready web app,
then yes, definitely
use Cloud Firestore.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm going
to ask the question,
because I do stuff in
gaming community stuff.
I would like to see
Unity and C++ SDKs.
Can we have some please?
ALEX DUFETEL: So this has
been an important request.
It's definitely something
that we would love to build.
We don't have that on
our immediate roadmap,
but we care very much
about that as well.
MARK MANDEL: Can people
hassle you for it?
ALEX DUFETEL: They can.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How?
DAN MCGRATH: If there's
something missing--
well, there is a
discussion group
you can join on Google Groups.
Just look for Google
Cloud Firestore Discuss.
And just tell us not just Unity
and C++ SDKs that you might be
looking for, but anything else
that you think will really
flesh out the
experience for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
also, we're going
to be sharing both of
your Twitter handles,
so there you go.
MARK MANDEL: So people
can bug you directly.
ALEX DUFETEL: All right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just saying.
Cool, so we're
running out of time.
But we always like to give
the opportunity to our guests
to plug whatever
you want to add.
Or is there anything
that we left unsaid
that you think is important
our audience knows?
DAN MCGRATH: So one
thing I want to say.
Get out there and play with it.
You don't need a credit card.
It's got a pretty
awesome free tier.
So you can use the SDKs today.
See what it's like.
See how it's going
to work for your app
without having to
commit anything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
That's a really,
really good point.
MARK MANDEL: That's
a good point.
ALEX DUFETEL: Yeah, just
echoing what Dan says.
Our purpose is to make
developers efficient and happy,
so tell us what you
think of the product
and how we can improve it.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds great.
Are any YouTube
videos, or blog posts,
or documentation--
particular places
people should go to
learn about this stuff?
ALEX DUFETEL: So there's a
blog post on the Firebase blog.
Definitely read that.
There's actually
two blog posts--
one generally talking
about the product,
one more specifically
going into the differences
with the Realtime Database.
I'd recommend reading both.
And then we ship the product
with an extensive set
of documents.
So definitely read up there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
We'll have links to all of
those from the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, thank you to both of
you for joining us today
on the podcast to talk to
us all about Firestore.
I think our listeners will
greatly appreciate it.
DAN MCGRATH: Thank you.
ALEX DUFETEL: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
again to Dan and Alex
for spending such a
delightful time with us
to talk all about
Cloud Firestore.
A really, really cool project.
I'm actually quite excited
to sit down and play with it
and see what I can build.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm also very excited by that
last mention of oh, by the way,
you can try it for free.
No credit card needed.
That makes it even
easier to try.
So I'm definitely going to
play a little bit with it
and see how it can help me build
even better real-time stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I know.
And I love the--
there was a focus
there, I think, more
on the web side of things.
I definitely don't do that
much mobile programming,
so I think I'm really
kind of curious to see
what I can do on the web side.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Really, really exciting.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we get stuck
into our question of the week.
I think this is an
interesting one.
So we're talking about
Datastore this time.
Datastore's been around
for a really long time.
I've wanted to always be able to
do imports and exports of data
out of Datastore, right?
Datastore's kind of proprietary.
We built it.
It's a thing.
It's quite powerful.
But maybe I want to pull
data down for backups,
or I want to put it in BigQuery
or something like that.
What tools, what things do I
have available to me there?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So this
is an interesting one,
because it's been
changing over the time.
And at some point-- so
Datastore's beginning was just
the way you store
data from App Engine.
It was available
only from App Engine.
And back then, in
order to do backup
or to export all of the
data, what you had to do
was to go into some
console and run MapReduce.
That would actually
run a MapReduce,
and you would see the process.
And you would end up
storing all of this
into some files in a
Cloud storage bucket.
Now, the thing is that there
was no API for this at all.
So you had to go
and do it manually.
Now, that thing has been
replaced with something
that we call the Manage
Export and Import Service.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, Sounds fancy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Which, it's fancy,
but it's beta, just so you know.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's an
important thing to know.
And basically, it allows
you to export and import
data in a very, very simple way.
And it's very exciting,
because this time,
rather than being only
part of the console,
it's more like what
we do nowadays.
So it's part of the
API, which you can also
use from GCloud directly.
So super simple,
and you end up being
able to download all the
contents of your Datastore.
So then you can upload
it to other places,
like let's say you want
to upload it to BigQuery
or whatever-- very
simple to do from there.
You can also upload
into Datastore.
And I know that some
people want to do
these kind of things for QA.
So you have a golden
image or something
like that, where you
get that file, upload it
to the Datastore, and then
you start running from there.
MARK MANDEL: This is nice.
I'm actually having a
look through as well,
and I'm seeing that there is a--
it looks like IM permissions
as well to hook in here so
that you can dictate who or
even what services could then
be able to import and export.
So people who shouldn't be
able to just go, oh, look, I
can import into
production, that's fine.
You'd have a lot of
control over this.
This looks actually really nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The only warning
that I would give
to anyone doing
this is when you
are doing a backup,
you will be charged the price
of reading those entities.
So it's something
to keep in mind.
I mean, it makes sense,
because you're actually
reading those entities.
But keep in mind that if
you have a huge database,
and you're taking backups every
hour, that might be expensive.
So take that into account
and be careful with that.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Francesc, before we wrap
up today, what are you up to?
Where are you going?
Is there a JustforFunc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There was
a first part of JustforFunc
that I released just last week.
And next week, I'll
release the second part
of the same
JustforFunc, which is
code review of some cool
package which I already
forgot what it did.
It was cool.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
We'll check it out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, no,
it was a URL shortener.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it was a cool thing.
I remember.
And yeah, after that, so
I will be going to London.
So on the week of the 17th to
the 20th, it's going to be fun.
On the 17th, I'm going to
be speaking at the Go meetup
in London.
On the 18th, I'll be
speaking at Velocity, London.
On the 19th, I'll be speaking
at Google Cloud Summit in Paris.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm not going
anywhere for about two or three
weeks, which is wonderful.
Then I'm off to Australia--
DevFest, Melbourne.
I'll be there on
the 21st of October,
hanging out at Unite Melbourne.
I'll be speaking at Game
Connector Asia Pacific.
And then I'll be at Pax
Australia after that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So yeah, if you see
us around, say hi.
Let us know.
It was really cool to
meet a bunch of people
last week in Chicago that
loved the podcast, so thanks so
much for our viewers to say hi.
Also, please review
our podcast on iTunes.
And we've been told
to say that, so.
[LAUGHING]
MARK MANDEL: We got told
we have to say that?
Yes, please do review our thing
on iTunes and give it stars.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
five stars or more.
MARK MANDEL: All the stars.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or more.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And also,
please get in touch with us
if you have questions.
We love questions of the week.
Let us know if you
have interested
on having some specific topic
that you'd like us to cover,
like I don't know--
do you want us
to talk more about server-less,
or Kubernetes, what?
More about Kubernetes, I don't
think it's possible anymore.
But whatever topic
you're interested in.
And in order to do that,
you can get in touch with us
on Twitter--
MARK MANDEL: @GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On Reddit--
MARK MANDEL: /r/GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
On Google Plus--
MARK MANDEL: +GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On Myspace--
MARK MANDEL: We don't have one
of those, but maybe we should.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
should have a MySpace.
Wait, what else?
We're on Slack.
MARK MANDEL: Slack at
the #podcast channel
bit.ly/GCP/slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then
finally, we have a web page--
MARK MANDEL: GCPpodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And an email--
MARK MANDEL: Hello@GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Perfect.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
Well, Francesc, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]